coupe c'est beau comme ça avec
contrejour derrière c'est joli
ça derère pas trop pas trop deant parce
qu'près je vais gen le
flair allez ça y est je l'ai on reprend
du champ alors attends attends ça y est
je
l'ai
on ref un tour attend attend
pas notre gauche je le vois pas ce
important c'est
ça
coupe
c
des derrièreie de
faire quiig tout
çaoute pas grave on l' comme ça une
fois
c'est beau ça c'est joli ça
joli vasy arrêteoi un
peu ok ok ok c'est beau c'est beau çae
là tu vas trouver attends attends
attends attends 2 secondes un peu serré
pourir le truc ATT coupe dessus
tranquille Derrien c'est beau ça
c'est fa vraiment qu'on découvre si pr
le temp pour la fin derrière qui fr là
c'est bon si tu l'as commence à l'avoir
à droite en haut
je peux ouvrir la porte pas Fran tu
attacher je attacher
je va aller jusqu'au jusqu'au bateau en
ruine là tu veux faire
ouais VO un peu plus bas peut-êre
non
im comment il est
immense joli
ça
itoi pas trop pr trop
pr
nickel
plus for on va couper on va le
couper pasou entier juste un petit tu
vois juste l'image je saais pas c'est
pas grave c'est pas grave c'est grave
c'est très
grave
qui te ramène non j'avis pas prévu quoi
voilà je pensais
qu'on
le
qu'est-ce que tu as envie de faire
attends je termine
ça
e avec les les bateau
derrière
faut vraiment qu'on arrive tu vois vers
la pointe et qu' tu vois un peu qu'on a
la vision des gens qui veulent traverser
tu vois oui
oui qui a pe vous donner l'impression
donc il faut moner les bateaux découper
un
peu
bon on va faire peut-être une vue
pendant qu'on va tourner tu veux tourner
par
derrière tu veux prendre par
derrière V moi un pe d'ici pour voir la
pointe
onglis
là
je
l' alorsut en
Espagne
al regarde le rocher en
large vasy vasy vasy faire tu ser contre
jour attention attention attention
regarde ce que tu peux faire toi je peux
pas prendre de
champ la
poin
le ave les derrière vois le baroc
derrière ou pas max de l'ARG ou pas ou
je mer
descend ça c'est pas exploitable c'est
joli ça pour le mon
dommage super beau tuas le Maroc juste
derrière un peu brumassou tu
dire tous les
bateaux un contrejour avec le le rocher
là attention les baffes
éventuel non j'ai du flire même moi j'ai
du flire laisse tomber là ça c'est Dom
que vachement derrière
to pe maisons ce comp c'est
joli tomber
çaitable bateau si tu veux
ferme attends
coupe coupe coupe parce que ça
ça OK et là j'ai un flair ok tu peux
couper céit beau même avec un flair
c'est joli de la voir ça peut TJ servir
ça
tourne
a d le prendre ce matin comme ça en
arrivant tu vois en hauteur on a fait un
peu le con la lumière était pas très
très belle
non oh là
là
voilà d'accord on s'éloigne on descend
et on fait l'arrivée sur de loinz dans
terminons ça parce que là je l'ai le
plan là
ok qu'on tourne un peu vers la droite
oua comme ça doucement tranquille on
voit bien on a le temps deuer c'est beau
tu vois dès que tu viens trop dans le
soleil c'est beaucoup moins
joli c'est bon
ça reste large c'est vach c'est
magnifique ça
voil
c'est BR Massou
hein
a
je descends un peu vers le bas tuas un
Ferri je sais pas devrait pas être loin
du Ferri à mon avis
et là si je prends du
champ je vouis prendre du champ tu vois
il veut pas qu'on ailles
l'Espagne faire quoi Fran prendre ch je
vouis prendre du champ pour avir Mar
derrière voilà tu vois il veut pas dès
que j'essaye allez allez on seit
l'arrivver tu
fini
tu te vois sur le radar là ah ou voilà
mon
av transpur
ouis là on fait l'arrivée dans
Lear sil vous plî enaubr
important là on est pas dans ce qu'on a
parti faire c'est pas il AR loin avec le
ok le truc ça voilà on soit bien tard
Leit bien au R de l'eau je sais pas
j'ais bien faire un truc comme si
quelqu'un arriv un bateau quoi tu
vois
que le bateau rouge peutêtre bienc le
bateau rouge devant là penses
ouais au télé tu vois il faut prendre du
champ BL de
champ le soleil va tomber dans un dé
nuag dans un qu d'heure il y a plus de
soleil à mon avis
c'est beau là d'ici tu
vois ça
c'est à mon avis c'est ça
le la terre prise par que on va bien le
rocher là ouais VO dans l'utre sens
on voit trop de face on per côté du
rocher
quoi
voilà pour en faire un autre avec le
bateau rouge devant si on veut
to voilà
la même chose mais le brocher plus petit
hein
aprs oh des
dauphins des dauphins là énorme énorme
où
pardon excuse-moi je t'en prie je t'en
prie tu les as là il VI de plonger là
voir
attends il on plonger avec
leéli
énorme Bale je sais pas c une queue
énorme en tout cas c'est une Bale c'est
pas c ah ou
grosse tu as coupé tu me dis je 360
qu pr bateau qui est en ruine là moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on fe un plan le
bateau en ruine s'il te plaît
çae bateau est éclairé c'est noir
derrière donc c'est
impressionnant la droite voilà
voilà je crois que c'était une Bale ah
c'est une grosse oui
forcément
voilà
voilà le bateau qui do à côté doit être
un bateau qui doit servir à la rlouer à
mon avis
en tout ce qui était dans les tu sais
regarde regarde la
pointe plus j tout à l'heure
lap les deux
pointes
CELI c'est le bateau avec le rochet
derrière
voilà voilà doucement c'est vachement
beau
ça les oiseaux
aour
super lumière sur le sur le
bateau pour ustrer c'est bien pour
ustrer les
ou dans les D3 tu vois parce que les D3
il passe tellement de bateaux
aujourd'hui là il do passer un paquet de
bateaux là tous les jours je peux te
dire je va faire une photo pant j'y suis
là pardon tu te rapprocher un tout je
sais pas pour toi que attends c'est qui
décide c'est B c'est bon tu fais comme
tu veux c'est bien ça c'est bien c'est
bien pas
d'accord vas-y pas trop deed quand même
couper comment sans couper le de
C
voilà voors on voit tout
bien
ge moi un
peu c'est un prétexte faut pas pas trop
trop en faire de attends attends fini
ton plan mais c'est vraiment l'arrivée
qui est important tu vois l'arrivée dans
la mer le truc noir au bout que tu
découvres tu as vraiment envie d'y
arriver quoi tu
vois
un bateau ce truc làavantin
voilà bien arrié ce bateau abîmé là je
pense que c'est non qu'est-ce que tu en
penses c'est le plus symbolique faut le
refaire bien ça à mon avis c'est le plus
symbolique et le plus B faire sur le
bateau rouge c'est bien ce que j'aime
c'est qu'on est assez loin et que tu as
le bateau éclairé derrière Le Roch noir
tu vois euh euh ouais yes